In today's video,
we are taking a look
at three different types
of fire extinguishers,
how they put out three different
types of fire, and why.
[Music]
Guys, we are up here at the Dome
today with three different types
of fire extinguishers
because we want to take a look
at just what's inside them,
and what kind of tires
they can put out.
So to start out with,
we need some fire.
Yay, fire!
So first, let's talk
about the different types
of fire extinguishers you can
normally find for your house.
This is the most
common fire extinguisher
you're normally going to find.
This is your ABC
fire extinguisher.
Now, A, B and C stand for
three different types of fires.
So any type of fire
that starts with wood,
paper, trash,
that's a solid fire
and that's a Class A.
A Class B fire is
actually going to be liquids.
So if you have a gasoline fire,
or an oil fire,
something like that,
you would use this
with the type B.
You also have the type C,
which is an electrical fire.
Now, while these
can be used on electronics,
it's not typically the one
that you want to use
if you want to save
your electronics,
because this will actually
produce a residue.
This is another type
of fire extinguisher
that's slightly newer
in the market.
This is specifically made
for kitchen grease fires.
As far as I'm aware,
this is the only
UL-approved kitchen grease
fire fire extinguisher.
The first ingredient
in this fire extinguisher is
actually sodium bicarbonate,
which is just baking soda.
Now, this is going
to put out any sort
of grease fire supposedly.
We're going to test that.
But again, it's going
to ruin your food.
This is a third
fire extinguisher.
A lot of times you can find
these in office settings.
Now, I've never actually used a
Tundra fire extinguisher before.
Supposedly, this is
an aerosol powered foam spray.
Now, I've never used it.
I'm not even sure what
the ingredients are.
I searched and I
could not find out online
what Tundra uses
in their fire extinguishers,
so we want to take a look at it.
[Music]
That's probably enough.
Note, oil has a flash point
of 619 degrees Fahrenheit,
and the fire point
of 662 degrees Fahrenheit.
So that's what we're trying
to get this to.
Now, we also have
some handheld flares today.
Now, technically, none
of our fire extinguishers are
made to put out chemical fires,
but I want to see if they can.
These aren't even road flares.
These are Marine flares.
Never used one this before.
We stepped away
for maybe 30 seconds,
and our oil is on fire.
That was fast.
Grease fires in the kitchen
are extremely dangerous,
because a lot of times
people will panic,
they will try
and pick up the pot,
and throw it outside.
But you could splash it.
You could spread the fire
everywhere or burn yourself.
Another problem with
a grease fires is
that people will try
and throw water on them.
Now, water is not going
to do anything.
It just splashes.
It's just gonna make it worse.
So that's why you use a dry
chemical fire extinguisher,
or a CO2 fire extinguisher.
Either of those will work.
I'm going to try
one of ours now.
[Music]
That's a lot of fire.
That's why you don't throw
water on a grease fire.
That's not putting it out.
What it's doing is
it's actually splashing the oil
and spreading it around.
That one burned itself
out because again,
we're not using too much oil.
It's time for round two.
[Music]
So last time,
it took us about two and a half
minutes with our oil on top
of our forge to hit that flash
point and auto-ignition.
All right, 47 seconds.
It's bubbling.
No smoke yet though.
Five minutes.
There we go.
5 minutes, 21 seconds.
[Music]
So now, we're gonna use
our fire extinguisher
that's specifically made
for fires of these type.
We're going to try and catch
some of our baking soda
and the other ingredients in one
of the bowls to look at the bit.
Now, these cans,
a lot of people think
that they spray
for quite a long time.
They actually have about 8
to 10 seconds of spray time.
So you need to move quick.
Aim for the base of your fire
from about five
to six feet away.
Make sure that you put
the whole thing out.
Usually, you want to make sure
that you're aiming all of it
into the container
before you back way.
But like I said,
we're gonna let a lot
of this burn off,
and then I'll try
and capture some as well.
[Music]
Well, that is very useful.
This is a good example
of why CO2 fire extinguishers
are sometimes nice.
Yes, that put out our fire
very very quickly.
But if that was dinner,
now it's covered
in baking soda,
and so is your entire kitchen.
So here's what
you're going to find
if you ever discharged
a kitchen fire extinguisher.
So it's not that foam
and it's not water
like you might see in movies,
it's a dry chemical.
Now, this is a bit
of an irritant.
So I actually held my breath
when I was over there,
got out of the dust
cloud very quick,
because well, it's not going
to be too hurtful for you.
It can cause irritation
to your eyes and lungs.
You don't want to breathe it in.
[Music]
I do have quite a bit
of water with me,
and water does put
out solid fires.
But I want to test
our fire extinguisher
that's specifically made for it,
our ABC fire extinguisher.
Now, the main ingredient
in this one,
like I said before is
monoammonium phosphate.
Again, I'm going
to spray the fire,
and then I'm going to try
and capture some of this so we
can look at it afterwards too.
So for this one,
you're going to stand
six feet back.
So it's a little
bit farther back
than you need to be
with your kitchen fire.
You aim at the base of the fire,
never at the top of the flames.
[Music]
That was so fast.
Now, this you absolutely
do not want to breathe in.
Spray and then get away.
We have our two different types
of dry powder fire
extinguisher substances here.
You can already
see the difference.
So this one,
you can see the mono
ammonium phosphate already has
that strange yellowish tinge.
This one, baking soda.
So now, I want to go and put
this through a few other tests.
This stuff is not supposed to
be able to put out a gas fire.
I still want to put some in our
forge just to see what it does.
[Music]
So first, I'm just
going to try sprinkling
some of this in there.
And again, main ingredient
is baking soda.
Oh.
Well, that was awesome.
It actually did dampen
the flames for a little bit.
[Music]
Wow, that is a much cooler
reaction than I was expecting.
I'm just wondering
if it's the quantity,
or if this is a small
enough contained fire
that it's easy enough
for the ingredients
to just snuff it out.
This again would be your normal
kitchen fire extinguisher
that's used for grease fires.
Let's try our ABC
fire extinguisher.
[Music]
Well, that's awesome.
This is actually changing
the color of the flames.
I don't know why,
but that's awesome.
So we've already seen
that tossing in a little bit
of our fire extinguishing powder
will put out our gas flames
for just a couple of seconds.
I'm actually going to try
and pour it into a crucible,
and super heat it just
to see what it does.
[Music]
Not expecting any
huge reactions here.
Because if this were to melt
or burn or anything else,
it wouldn't be really useful
for a fire extinguisher.
So it's been a few minutes.
Our Crucible is red-hot,
and nothing has happened to our
ABC fire extinguishing powder.
So we're going
to turn this one off.
Kind of what we expected.
But that's pretty cool.
So, for our last test,
we have got our Tundra
fire extinguisher.
Like I said before,
I know that this
is an aerosol can,
and I'm pretty sure
that this is going
to be a foam spray,
but I'm not positive.
We're going to put
this to the test up
against a marine flare.
Now, these are
technically chemical fires.
None of the extinguishers
that we have used today are
meant to put out chemical fires.
Let's see if they can.
[Music]
Now, this is something that's
kind of interesting to note.
While there is
a huge size difference,
this fire extinguisher
only has a lasting spray
of about 8 to 10 seconds,
whereas the Tundra has about
32 seconds of spray time.
So while it does have
a longer lasting spray,
you actually have to be
even closer to the fire.
So that's a huge downside
to one of these.
The other ones,
you can be five-six feet away.
This one have to be about
three feet from the fire
to actually put it out.
Thankfully, our marine flare
is a very contained fire.
So I'm safe enough
to get that close and see
if this is gonna work.
[Music]
Huh?
Still going.
All right, I would have been
very disappointed in this flare
if it had a gone out
because it's a marine flare.
Let's try again though.
[Music]
Oh, this is interesting.
It's not really a foam.
It's basically a water.
[Music]
It's definitely a liquid,
and it has definitely
put out our flare.
Liquid foam fire extinguishers
versus Marine flare,
fire extinguisher wins.
So these are the fire
extinguishers that we use today
because they are
the most common ones
that you're going to find
around your house,
around your workspaces,
but there are actually five
types of fire extinguishers.
These are just the ones
that were going to be easiest
for us to test,
and kind of show you
what they're going to do,
and the ones
that are going to be most
readily available to you.
So, your fire extinguishers.
Are they going to put out
the fires they're supposed to?
Absolutely.
Turns out that they can put
out a few other things too.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle
to get subscribed to the club
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.